hang out with more Fox Business host
Larry Kudlow Larry great to have you the
first thing that people need to
understand is this this problem with the
debt ceiling is not imminent we're
looking at May or June before it really
becomes a significant issue Kevin
McCarthy rightly is has been trying to
negotiate with Joe Biden Joe Biden has
said no to those negotiations the very
opposite of what he said in 2011 uh when
they came up with the uh deficit
reduction act and sequestration followed
that so the question is why won't Joe
now negotiate does he think the
Republicans won't unite behind Kevin
McCarthy does he think he's able to
break the Republican Coalition because I
can predict tonight after talking to
many factions in the Republican party
that's not going to happen they're going
to be together
well Sean you know it's very important
Biden and uh Schumer and Jeffrey's uh
they're all giving us this big lie
here's the big lie the publicans are
gonna cut into Social Security the
Republicans are going to cut Medicare
the Republicans are going to default on
the debt it is a complete lie Sean this
week in recent days today and two days
ago I interviewed uh speaker Kevin
McCarthy today I interviewed Majority
Leader Steve scalise they both said
emphatically they're not going after
Social Security they're not going after
Medicare and they will make good on the
government debt so what you got here is
Biden with this big lie you know this is
what authoritarians do this is what
totalitarians do they say something
that's not true they keep repeating it
and they hope that somehow it's going to
become true
McCarthy's too smart for this school Ace
is too smart for this probably the
country's too smart for this the basic
Point here is the Democrats will do
anything Sean not to cut spending and
right now spending and the bloated size
of government is the single biggest
problem it is the single biggest
obstacle to economic growth and
prosperity middle income folks are
getting killed so this is just craziness
this big lie and they're just denying it
I mean I I've been playing it on my show
they were the leaders of the Republican
house are not going to do it and Biden's
just just going out with this baloney
and Malarkey it's like some totalitarian
dictator
96 debt to GDP ratio right now that is
almost a a mathematical certainty that
inflation will continue and will
continue with a bad economy but I want
to take you back to 2011 Joe Biden
comments he made on debt ceiling
negotiations now he's saying no
negotiations how can you explain the
fact that grown men and women are
unwilling to budge up until now and
still some of them are still unwilling
to budge by taking an absolute position
my way or no way that's not governing
that's no way to govern you can't govern
that way this is a cycle I predict to uh
to you that a lot of those new members
who came here with my way or the highway
they'll either be on the highway or
learn that they're going to have to
compromise so I am betting and I think
the Democratic party is betting on that
the Republican party in the house will
not stick together I have spoken to all
of the top players that I think are
going to have a key role in all of them
this they've all said the same thing
they will unite around a position
there's about 15 different plans being
tossed around they're all dealing with
spending and they'll agree that's my
prediction what's yours
well I basically agree look the position
that Biden that he's not going to
negotiate cannot hold all right
Republicans will stick together and by
the way they're going to get some
democratic support in the house and even
in the Senate look
to raise the debt ceiling they're going
to have to have budget cuts otherwise
we're going to continue with this
inflation and we're going to continue
with what looks like a recession today's
GDP number was really a lousy number
when you look under the hood you know go
back to 2011 Sean I like that John
Boehner
toughed it out with Barack Obama and
Boehner got spending caps okay Boehner
got a reduction in overall spending
Bader stopped tax hikes Barack Obama
started out you know arrogantly not
negotiating Boehner succeeded okay I
think that um Kevin McCarthy and Steve
scalise and the others will also succeed
I wish you think they're going to get
some help from the Senate this time
around but the crazy point is
the government is spending 24 of our
economy if you go to the states and the
localities federal state and local 44 of
our economy and that's why you're
getting for all of 22. you just got the
last numbers today the economy grew at
one percent Sean that's the worst
performance since the financial meltdown
in 2008 and 2009 the inflation rate for
the whole year was 6.3 percent that is
the highest inflation in 40 years what's
the culprit here
five to six trillion dollars of spending
and borrowing okay and then student debt
cancellations could add another six
eight hundred billion so no you're right
there will be negotiations the GOP is
not going to destroy the big entitlement
programs the GOP will make good on the
debt but here's the thing they will
insist on spending cuts on new caps for
future and they'll also have the penalty
of across-the-board sequester across the
board automatic Cuts this is coming and
all the big lies from Joe Biden and the
leading Democrats will not stop it the
public wants lower spending because
that's the obstacle to Prosperity right
now
Larry Kudlow always great to have you
thank you my friend and